okay welcome back everyone today we're
gonna kind of finish off our discussion
about analytic solutions to PD es okay
so we know about the Laplace transform
we know the Laplace transforms can be
super useful for solving OD es and we're
gonna find out that similar to two
Fourier transforms Laplace transforms
give us the ability to turn a partial
differential equation into an ordinary
differential equation
which is a huge simplification okay so
I'm going to do two examples in class
today and then on Friday I think we're
gonna move towards just doing some
numerical solutions to PDE s because I
want you to know that you can solve
things that aren't just simple linear
wave equation or simple linear heat
equation or simple linear plus on or
Laplace equation okay so we might do
something like nonlinear Schrodinger or
complex ginsberg landau or something
that is a little bit nastier and more
non-linear that we can do in a computer
but we can't do on the board okay good
so I'm just gonna do two examples for
the Laplace transform on a PDE because I
think that's the best way to explain how
this thing works is just to show you so
how what types of partial differential
equations are good for Fourier transform
solutions
they're telling me things about the PDE
that might make you think aha I should
be using a Fourier transform this is
important right because when you are in
the real world you're gonna have a PDE
and you're gonna need to solve it you're
gonna have to think to yourself oh hi
better use this method or else you're
just gonna have to try everything until
something works sorry
so periodic would be good if you wanted
to use a Fourier series but not before
you transform so it should be somewhat
continuous it actually doesn't have to
be yeah it has to be continuous ensure
you continuous good it should be
integral meaning it's kind of bounded as
you go to infinity and what else if you
have no game that goes to infinity so
it's great for a thick for functions
that are kind of defined on an infinite
domain and are not necessarily periodic
on a finite domain
okay what about boundary conditions and
initial conditions what do I need if I
want to solve the system using Fourier
transforms alright I need some initial
condition at all points space X at time
0 and I need the kind of simple boundary
condition that things get boring at
infinity ok so Laplace transforms is
similar they're good for PD es but
they're good for PD es on a semi
infinite domain so instead of negative
infinity to infinity we're gonna use
Laplace transforms on half infinite
domains so semi infinite domain and that
just means that X has to be greater than
or equal to 0 but it can go up to
positive infinity so the first example
we're gonna do is the infinitely long
thin steel rod with some temperature
distribution except it's going to be
half infinite it's going to start at 0
and it's going to go to a positive
infinity ok so the equation for a heat
inner rod is what
UT something like that I hope this is
the first example I'm doing good okay
and let's just say that the heat
constant is one it will make our lives a
lot easier not having elbows floating
around okay
so we're gonna have this on X from 0 to
infinity and now what kind of initial
conditions and boundary conditions do I
need
I probably still need to know what the
temperature distribution is at time zero
all right I probably still need some
initial condition of what the
temperature is at time zero so I need
you at all of points X at time zero and
I'm just going to use these are values I
used in the last qualifying exam that I
wrote so I'm just salt I'm solving the
calls that I wrote last quarter so I
need some initial condition and this
isn't actually a sign but it would just
be some periodic sign would be the
initial condition
okay what else do I need what else did I
have in the Fourier transform case when
this went to positive and negative
infinity
it went 2-0 at the infinite boundary
conditions so Fourier transforms my
boundary conditions are kind of easy it
just goes to zero at infinity so here I
also have that this is going to go to
zero at infinity but then I also have
this left boundary condition okay and I
need to figure out what's happening at
this left boundary condition so what are
the types of things I could impose at
this left boundary condition it's a real
physical end of a steel rod and I can do
stuff to it so what do i impose as a
boundary condition could be insulating
it could be u x equals 0 I could fix a
temperature u equals a I can make a
function I could have a controller
that's actively pumping in energy to
keep this at a constant temperature okay
so my boundary condition here is going
to be u at the point x equals 0 so at
the left point for all times t is going
to be some function that i prescribed
we're just going to make it easy e to
the minus T okay so my boundary
condition is just an exponentially
decaying temperature that I'm imposing
on the Left boundary condition it could
be insulating it could be a fixed
temperature it could be zero anything
that's fine so this is my boundary
condition red is my initial condition
okay good and what we're going to see is
that when we Laplace transform this
equation the initial condition and the
boundary condition are essentially going
to play the roles of forcing in in the
analog of ordinary differential
equations okay so we want to solve for u
the temperature distribution and we're
going to Laplace transform our equation
so what variable do you think we should
Laplace transform in we get to choose
right we can Laplace transform with
respect to time or space
okay why do you feel like space okay I
have two derivatives so let's say I
Laplace transform with respect to space
so let's try L with respect to space
okay so what is my right-hand term look
like if I Laplace transform with respect
to space s squared u bar and that's a
function of s comma t minus s u bar
first derivative and X evaluated at x
equals zero and time t minus u bar
evaluated at all times at point x equals
zero right this is just the analog of
like s squared Y bar minus s y dot at
zero minus y of zero if this was a no de
right with two derivatives this is what
I would get now you always have to ask
yourself when you're doing this Laplace
transform do I actually have all of the
information that I'm being asked for
here do I have this term U bar of sorry
this is not a u bar this is just you do
I have you evaluated at x equals zero at
all points in time okay that's my
boundary condition right so yes I have
this one what about this term here do I
know you sub X at my left boundary at
all points in time no I don't have this
I don't have insulating boundary
conditions I don't I don't know what
this solution is at all points at all
points in in time right look I just
don't have another I we need a second
boundary condition to just solve this
using Laplace transform in space just
like if you're doing an ordinary
differential equation let's say I had X
double dot plus X dot plus x equals zero
and I just tell you X
zero equals one you can't solve this
because you need to boundary you need
two initial conditions you also need to
know what X dot equals right so you
wouldn't be able to solve this equation
with Laplace transforms unless you had
two conditions one on X and one on X dot
so the same thing applies here because I
have two derivatives in the X variable I
would need two boundary conditions and I
only have one so I definitely cannot do
Laplace transform in space if I gave you
another boundary condition you certainly
could if I specified that u sub X at
zero and T equals five you could do this
no problem okay this is also a question
I always ask on the calls like I give
you a Laplace transform solution and I
would ask you to justify why you choose
the variable you choose and if you could
do it in the other variable so you have
to really be thinking about what the
boundary conditions and initial
conditions are telling you okay good so
Laplace transform with respect to space
doesn't work so let's try with respect
to time okay so the Laplace transform
with respect to time now what do I get
for my term on the left hand side s u
bar and now this is a function of X and
s so time is replaced by my Laplace
variable minus U at X comma 0
so we're Laplace transform with respect
to time so we care about time zero for
this evaluation and then on the right
hand side I just have u bar sub X X
second partial derivative of u bar with
respect to X ok good now this is a
simple ordinary differential equation
and we do in fact have this term here
and it's interesting if I took the
Laplace transform in space then I'll be
using my boundary conditions but because
I'm taking the lost Laplace transform in
time
this is my initial condition kind of
interesting okay so the initial
condition is this term here in my
laplace transformed equation good now
I'm going to rewrite this equation this
is just an ordinary differential
equation okay this is an OD e u xx
equals u times some constant plus some
forcing term so let's see if I can
rewrite this in a nice way u X X u bar
xx plus s u bar equals u of equals [ __ ]
- equals minus U of X and 0 so this is
just rewriting this so it looks like an
ordinary differential equation like
we're used to and this here is my
forcing term so my initial Candice is
weird okay this sounds like it's a
little weird when I say it out loud the
initial temperature distribution is like
a forcing term on this equation when I
love Australian that's exactly what it
looks like the forcing term okay you
could if this was a wave equation if
this is a guitar string from 0 to L then
plucking the string would be the forcing
term and it would look a lot like this
you'd give it some initial condition
like I'd bend the string and let it go
and it would look like a forcing term
okay good if this term was 0 we could
solve this ordinary differential
equation and that we would get the
homogenous solution but since we have a
forcing term we have the homogeneous
solution and a particular solution and
so I'm just going to write out what I
think this is going to look like so we
think that
you bar of X and s is going to equal the
homogeneous solution to this and just
how would I find the homogeneous
solution of this OD if I forget forcing
I mean this is a lot like Y double dot
minus lambda y equals 0 and so I would
get like e to the plus and minus square
e to the e to the plus and minus square
root of lambda or e to the plus and
minus square root of s and you can
verify that I don't get an eye popping
out because if this moves over it's
actually positive it's not negative ok
so I have some coefficient a times e to
the minus root s times X plus another
constant B times e to the plus root s
times X plus some particular solution
I'm gonna call it sy because sighs
sounds like particular to me okay this
is just how we solve an OD e we write
down the homogeneous solution this part
plus the particular solution to forcing
and I am going to note that these
constants are actually functions of my
Laplace variable so these are Laplace
transform functions a of s and B of s
any questions so far
no okay and then one last simplification
so I'm gonna call this I'm just gonna
call this the particular solution so we
don't forget what it is and I'm also
going to say because I have a boundary
condition that my temperature
distribution has to decay to zero and
infinity I'm just assuming infinity is
really cold or zero one of these terms
has to be zero so if I plug in x equals
positive infinity here then this term
gets really really small so that's good
but if I turn in if I plug in positive
infinity here this thing blows up and so
the only way to mitigate this growing
term is to make B equal to zero so B has
to equal zero for infinite BC for my
infinite boundary condition okay good
now whenever I have an ordinary
differential equation with forcing
usually what I do is I solve it first
for the homogeneous case and then I
solve it for the particular case and
then I add them together so that's what
we're gonna do here except I'm gonna
solve the particular solution first
because it's a little bit easier I think
it's actually not easier but I do it
first in my notes okay so let's solve
for the particular solution
okay the particular solution is the
solution due to forcing due to these red
initial conditions and we know that my
initial conditions look like a sine
function so I'm going to be taking some
function and that function second
derivative and X minus f times that
function is going to equal sine of 4x
okay so my particular solution I'm going
to guess is sines and cosines this is
what we did before when we had a
particular solution that was like e to
the something we would guess it was e to
the something if it's sines and cosines
we're gonna guess that it's sines and
cosines so let's say that sigh of X and
s equals some constant C times cosine of
4x plus some other constant d times sine
of 4x and our only job now is to find
the constant C and D so that when I plug
this into my OD e
it all balances out with the particular
solution okay so what do I do
next I need u xx and I need s x you or
sy xx and s10 subside okay so what is sy
X x equals well okay the first
derivative of coast for X is minus 4
sine for ya really are to be functions
of s and they are they're not gonna be
constants they're gonna be functions of
s they're constant with respect to X
that's so like you know when you
integrate something that has two
variables you get a constant of the
variable you're not integrating with
respect to you that's like what's
happening here these are really free
constants in s as long as they are
constant with respect to X that's fine
and you'll see that these are actually
are going to be real functions they're
gonna be functions of s okay so first
derivative of this with respect to X is
remember this thing as a constant with
respect to X so I can treat it like a
constant is minus 4 sine 4x take another
derivative I get minus 16 Coast for X so
I have minus 16 C bar coast 4x okay I
take the first derivative of this I get
4 coasts 4x take the second derivative I
get minus 16 sine 4x so I get another
minus 16 D of s sine 4x
good and I can just simplify a little
bit so this is just minus 16 times C of
s plus D of s sine 4x okay so we're just
going to take these two things and plug
it into that equation over there we're
gonna plug it right into here so what do
we have we have this thing okay minus 16
C bar of s cos 4x minus 16 D of s sine
4x minus s times I minus s times C bar
of s cosine 4x minus s times D bar of s
sine 4x and what is all of this equal
what does I xx minus s sy equal sine 4x
okay so it looks like our choice of
basis functions for this particular
solution was correct because we're just
getting couses and sines that's good
this should be pretty easy to figure out
what these constants have to equal I
think
okay so let's collect all of our sign
terms together and collect all of our
cosine terms together so we have s okay
we have C of s times s plus minus C of s
times s plus 16 cosines and then how
many signs do we have we have minus D of
s okay so we have minus 16 d of s minus
s D of s and then minus 1 sorry I'm
doing a terrible job of explaining I'm
simplifying this
this one yes yeah it definitely should
thank you okay and that's really
important to get the okay negative
negative this one should be positive
good okay so let's sorry I'm just
simplifying this trip so all we're doing
is we're taking all of our cosine terms
and we're writing them over here we have
minus C of s times s plus 16 kosis and
then we have this many sign for X's we
have three terms that have sine for X
and these are their coefficients and
they have to equal zero so the only way
that this can equal zero for all X is if
this constant is equal to zero because I
don't have any kosis so C bar of S has
to equal zero and here I have D bar of s
minus becomes a plus right this time so
D bar of s has to equal one over s plus
16 and if D bar equals one over s plus
16 then this term equals zero and we
have this equality that we're looking
for this is a really sorry I think
there's a much easier way to explain
this all we're doing is we're taking our
particular solution plug it into our
equation and finding out what C and D
have to equal to make it make equality
and we find that C has to equal zero
because there are no cosine terms in my
forcing and D has to equal 1 over 16 for
everything to balance perfectly with the
derivatives ok so my particular solution
is equal to 1 over s plus 16
sign for X we have a particular solution
now and it's nice we have a function of
s times the function of X so they're
kind of separated out which I like it's
going to make our lives a little bit
easier
okay now the last thing we have to do is
we have to identify what is the constant
a hat in this term we know that the B
term is zero we know what our particular
solution is so now all we have to do is
solve for a bar and we can solve for a
bar by just plugging in x equals zero
okay so we look at x equals zero so u
bar of zero comma s is equal to a bar of
s times e to the 0 e to the 0 is just 1
ok what is u bar at x equals 0
for Laplace variable s
I think of the boundary condition yeah
so I already use my initial condition
that was the forcing term that gave me
the particular solution now all I need
to do is I take the Laplace transform of
my boundary condition and that gives me
this term here that I need okay so a bar
of s is equal to the Laplace transform
of U of 0 T which I have that's my
boundary condition and the Laplace
transform of that is 1 over s plus 1 so
this equals 1 over s plus 1 so now I
actually have everything I need okay I'm
gonna write it all out so I have u bar
of X and s equals maybe I'll even color
code it so this a bar comes completely
from my boundary condition and so does B
bar so 1 over s plus 1 e to the minus
root s X plus my particular solution and
my particular solution is 1 over s plus
16 sine 4x and in some sense this is the
solution of my partial differential
equation the solution and the frequency
domain so maybe it's not as useful as a
time domain solution but this is in fact
a solution of the PDE if you plug this
in everything balances out this is the
solution of the partial differential
equation and it satisfies my initial
conditions and it sounds my satisfies my
boundary conditions so we have some
dynamics boundary conditions and initial
conditions and we used all of the
information we have and this is the only
solution that exactly satisfies all of
that information
okay questions before I inverse Laplace
transform this fortunately I have a
second example so we'll go through it
again and it'll make a little bit more
sense the second time around okay so
usually we actually care about what this
function does in time not just an X
right I don't live in X I don't
understand s space intuitively so I want
you of X comma T and how do I get that
inverse Laplace transform this whole
right-hand side okay a little bit tricky
this is the product of two transfer
functions so if I want to inverse
Laplace transform this I could inverse
Laplace transform this and then convolve
it with the inverse Laplace transform of
this that's what I'm going to do so that
equals e to the minus T convolution with
the inverse Laplace transform of this
fortunately I have a really big lookup
table and Mathematica and so the inverse
Laplace transform of this thing is kind
of nasty it is 1 over 2 times the square
root of pi time cubed who would have
known e to the minus 1 over 40 someone
got paid to figure this out a long time
ago ok and I'm not actually going to
expand this convolution but you could
write it as the integral from negative
infinity to infinity and plug all the
stuff in and you could do this
convolution if you really really want it
to or you can plug it into matlab
mathematica ok so now if I want to
inverse Laplace transform this time what
do I have to do
exactly sine of 4x is a constant with
respect to s so this is just a constant
it pops out of my Laplace transform so
all I do is inverse Laplace transform
this this one's way easier okay so the
inverse Laplace transform of 1 over s
plus 16 is e to the minus 16 T so it's
just e to the minus 16 T sine 4x done
okay and now we have an actual solution
of our partial differential equation if
I didn't force my left hand side at all
this term would go away if I had zero
boundary conditions this would go away
and it'll be way simpler SuperDuper
simple we'll just diffuse okay so that's
the flavor of how you solve a PDE with
Laplace transforms so you need more
information you need boundary conditions
and initial conditions and you need
enough boundary conditions or initial
conditions to satisfy the the amount of
derivatives that you have okay so now
that we've gone through all of the math
I want you to think again about if it's
why it's possible to solve this using
Laplace in time but not in space okay
any questions before we go on to another
example yeah yeah this is the inverse
Laplace transform of 1 over s plus 1
this is the inverse Laplace transform of
e to the minus root s X and if I wanted
to you know I could plug this into a
computer and numerically evaluate it but
this like I don't know how to solve the
integral off the top of my head and it
would take one or two boards to do so
I'm just writing it as a convolution if
you gave this to Matt Mathematica it
would know what to do probably and if it
didn't then then there's nothing we can
really do except solve it numerically
okay so that was an example where I had
to Laplace transform in time because I
only had because I had enough initial
conditions to solve it in time but I did
not have enough boundary conditions to
solve it in space and so now we're gonna
look at a kind of opposite problem where
we have enough to Laplace transform in
time but not in space okay no more
questions a little more time okay this
is this examples a little bit more
intuitive so here we're going to look at
the wave equation u TT equals c-squared
u xx and so this wave equation is
essentially the equation for information
travelling on a string a taut string so
for example if I took a guitar string
and I tied it to one end of the room and
I pulled it I started whipping one end
of it I could get information to travel
along this way of using this equation or
if instead of tying it to the wall I
tied it to two pieces of the guitar
itself and I started plucking it I could
get information to travel using this
equation this is the wave equation but
we're going to look at the wave equation
on a semi infinite string seems weird
why would you have a semi infinite
string so let's say that I have a string
that kind of goes off to infinity maybe
maybe you can approximate this but would
be a decent approximation of a semi
infinite top string sure you can think
of
maybe I'm towing their cable and it's a
super long cable and so as far as I'm
concerned this is you know hundreds of
meters long so I don't know like what's
happening at the end it's way far away
from me and since I'm pulling it and
it's got drag it's actually being held
relatively talk
okay so towing a cable this is a decent
approximation of what might happen if
you're telling a cable you can think of
other examples okay and what we're going
to do again I need to color code this
for boundary conditions and initial
conditions so I'm going to have a
boundary condition that I'm going to
take this string and I'm going to start
whipping it up and down F of T so I'm
going to take this taut string you can
just imagine it's tied to something ten
buildings away and it's really really
tight that's infinite and I'm just
whipping it up and down so we've all
done this when we were kids right you
all would take like the jump rope or
some telephone cable or something and
you'd like whip it around on the ground
and you'd watch all the cool waves
traveling through at least I did and you
know that when you whip this thing up
and down that history gets transmitted
down the cable so what we have is a
boundary condition u at x equals zero
for all time T is equal to some forcing
function f that I'm prescribing I'm f
and then I need to give this thing some
initial conditions and I'm going to
choose zero initial conditions I'm gonna
say this string starts out zero U of X
at time zero equals zero
and the derivative U sub T at X and
times zero equals zero so this thing is
really motionless it has no position
zero position and zero motion okay so I
have motionless initial conditions and I
have some external forcing boundary
conditions I'm forcing this thing
so what variable should be Laplace
transform with respect to okay if I
Laplace transform with respect to X then
I'm going to get s squared then I'll get
s squared
noubar minus s u sub X at 0 minus U of 0
I don't have u sub X so I have to
Laplace transform this with respect to
time because that's the one that I have
two initial conditions in okay so let's
look lost with respect to time is
everyone okay with wrt great with
respect to a time so we're gonna little
plus transform did I Laplace transform
with respect to time then that one two
okay these are both with respect to time
good
okay so let's Laplace transform with
respect to time and we're going to get
this term looks like s squared u bar of
X comma s and then we're going to have
minus s times u T at X 0 minus u of X 0
and that's going to equal C squared u
bar X X now this is the beauty of
Laplace transforms this is why we love
Laplace transforms is because if you
have really simple initial conditions
like motionless zero initial conditions
these terms both go away it's beautiful
I have a much much simpler system now I
have no external forcing now again think
about the guitar string example let's
say that I had this string pulled taut
from you know here to infinity and I
start plucking this thing I just pull it
down and I
go at times zero that would be a forcing
term or or if I like pushed it up that
would also be a forcing term so you know
plucking the guitar string is forcing in
the Laplace domain but here I have
motionless initial conditions it has
zero forcing and so my OTE becomes much
much simpler I just have u bar X x
equals s squared over C squared u bar
that's a really simple OTE that we know
how to solve
okay good so how do we solve this oh do
you
it looks a lot like Y dot dot equals
lambda Y lambda squared Y alright so
it's a lot like Y double dot equals
lambda squared Y where y equals you bar
dot equals partial partial X and lambda
equals s over C this is just an ordinary
differential equation like this so we
can solve this we say u bar of x comma s
is going to equal now again we have
these functions of s as constants so we
have a bar of s times e to the minus
lambda X plus B bar of s e to the plus
lambda X and there's no forcing right or
forcing the zero because our initial
conditions were simple which is great
okay again how do we now use our
boundary conditions to solve this we had
our initial conditions those made our OD
our Laplace sense solutions simple now
how do we use our boundary conditions
now I'm kind of implicitly assuming
because this thing is taught that it's
probably zero amplitude deflections at
infinity so that means that this term
has to be zero and that means B has to
be zero so just like in the heat
equation we're gonna say that B equals
zero for you know X going to infinity
boundary condition and so all we're left
with is this term here I mean this is
exactly like the other solution right
we're doing the Laplace transform in
time so we if we want to know what is a
so let's just ask ourselves what is a
well let's plug in x equals zero
and we get u bar at 0 comma s equals a
bar of s times 1 e to the 0 is 1 and u
bar of 0 comma s is just the Laplace
transform of my forcing function u bar
at 0 s is just the Laplace transform of
U of 0 T I just Laplace transform with
respect to time and so this equals
Laplace transform of F of T let's call
this f bar of s
and we have a solution it's actually
super simple this is way simpler than
the wave equation then the heat equation
so u bar of X comma s is equal to f bar
I mask the Laplace transform of my
initial conditions of my forcing my
boundary conditions times e to the minus
s over C X it's the solution of my wave
equation but we're in the Laplace
transform domain so it's not as useful
as it might be if we inverse Laplace
transforms okay does anyone off the top
of your head remember what the inverse
Laplace transform of e to the minus x
over CS is
no I didn't either it's a good one
though so U of X comma T is going to be
its it okay with everyone if I inverse
Laplace transform this one first and
then this one yeah okay so what we have
is okay I think that this would require
looking this up in a table you're going
to get some inverse Laplace transform of
this and it's going to be some nasty
expression and then you're going to
convolve it with universal plus
transform of this and when you convolve
them you get a simple expression and the
simple expression you get is a Heaviside
function of t minus x over c times my
initial conditions f of t minus x over c
there's some magic between here and here
this is a table okay it's not that hard
you can inverse Laplace transform this
you can convolve it with that you'll
find that this is exactly what you get
do we know what the Heaviside function
looks like yeah okay zero until it's not
and then it becomes one so my Heaviside
function h of t minus x over c let's say
i do this in time i'm increasing from
zero you know i'm increasing in time
then when time passes through x over see
this thing bumps up to one so let's use
a color here so when time goes to x over
see this thing bumped up to one that's x
over c but this is a partial
differential equation I can also
independently vary X for a fixed time so
let's say I look at this exact same
Heaviside function varying X so now this
is
x / c okay now now whenever X is less
than CT its 1 and whenever X is greater
than CT its 0 this kind of makes sense
what I'm doing I'm taking this Heaviside
function and thinking well for a fixed
point in space X if I go through time
this is what my heavy side looks like
and for a fixed point in time if I look
over all of space this is what my heavy
side looks like and so it turns out that
we can draw something called an XT
diagram I'm sure some of you have heard
of XT diagrams before in physics like
fluid dynamics and what this XT diagram
is going to tell us is information about
where the forcing has reached in this
string so far ok it's going to tell me
where the wavefront of the information
is in this string so I take this
information and I plot it in X and T so
it's an XT diagram so X is on the bottom
and then T is on the top and XT diagram
and what we have here is essentially a
line at what is this let's multiply by T
we get x equals CT is where this is
equal to 0 and so we have this line here
the x equals CTE line and this is the
wavefront of the information I'm putting
into my string so I had this string its
taut and I'm whipping it around giving
putting information let's say I'm
putting Morse code into this thing so
I'm trying to get some information
across the string these are the
locations in space that haven't reached
that information yet at a given time
and as time increases I open up more and
more of space more and more spaces
getting my signal the longer time goes
so down here is a dead region where you
equals zero here this is my wave front
and up here I'm actually having
information propagation so for example
let's do it in purple because that's
what my forcing looks like if I have
some forcing in time some f of T at x
equals zero then this information is
going to be propagated along these
characteristic lines and I can predict
exactly what u is going to be at some
location X at some time T by looking
backward and seeing what was I what was
my forcing at that time so I'm assuming
that this is traveling at a wave speed
see this this kind of make sense like it
should make physical sense the reason I
picked this string is because you can
actually picture what's happening here
you can picture the string I can send a
big pulse and what's gonna happen is
that big pulse is gonna travel down the
street the string it waves speed C and
that pulse will keep moving to farther
and farther X's as time increases okay
so this is an extremely useful diagram
for representing any kind of wave
phenomenon if I hit the hood of my car
with a marble the wave is going to
propagate out and I could draw a diagram
like this an XT diagram for that shock
waves any other kind of waves okay we'll
talk more about this on Friday thanks
you